janet throgmerton has been an educator
at fancy farm elementary school for 25
years
and a principal for 11 years
now the principal known as miss janet
that's no nonsense made headlines after
she took on
a new role as a bus driver and she
started driving the bus in order to help
students get home
after school during the pandemic so
without further ado i would love to
welcome miss janet to the show
hello hi principal
janet hello i'm so excited you can call
me miss janet that's what all the kids
call me now
miss janet i read a quote of yours
saying
that um schools must care for
the whole child what do you mean by that
may i ask
well you know we we're here to teach
kids
there's lots of academic skills that we
want them to have
but before they can learn anything
we have to make sure that their needs
are met not only here at school but
if they have needs at home and
especially you know during the pandemic
we need to be sure that all the things
that they need
are met so that they don't have any
obstacles to have to overcome
and can concentrate on the learning and
so that's what we mean by the whole
child but then you even went further and
started driving
the bus to pick kids up who weren't
getting to school can you tell me about
that
yes so um three years ago i got my cdl
to help drive field trips so it wouldn't
cost our schools so much
and so in doing that i made a deal with
the transportation director that
they would train me for my cdl and i
would also
substitute drive in the afternoons as
needed because drivers were already
in a shortage even before the pandemic
and then
once um once coveted hit i had two
drivers that
contracted covid uh one of them has uh
won her battle against copen and i have
another that's still in the hospital
um on on event and so after that
um i stepped in to drive every afternoon
uh for our kids to get home and and
today i started driving in the morning
as well so
it's definitely um added to my job
but i enjoy it because it ensures that
our kids
get to and from school safely and we
have them here
so they can learn now miss janet
i i think i'm having one of those days
where
i just i feel like i'm back in march
it's been
really difficult we've had a lot of
setbacks
it's been really scary i think you know
we kind of around the holidays people
traveled
i think there's the new strain what do
you say i want to be one of your
students right now
and tell me what you say to students and
parents to
calm them or to encourage them to be
strong and just put one foot in front of
the other right now
well we we've been offering
opportunities uh by appointment for
parents to come into our building
and to see how we have set kids six feet
apart and we're wearing masks and we're
doing those things
and then when school is in session we
are doing everything that we can
to sanitize uh to be um
as sanitary as we can in the cafeteria
in our restrooms
but we know that it's scary
but we also know that our lives have to
find a way to move on
yeah and so i try to assure them that um
you know we love their kids as much as
they love their kids and want to
do what's best for them so yeah you know
definitely those things
well i think that the way that you care
for the whole child
is really um a model that i can
appreciate as a parent
uh sometimes you know i hear kids aren't
meeting expectations i've heard it about
my own kids
it's like the last thing you want to
hear right now you're like
are you kidding and it's just it's all
so difficult
so to know that these children are with
someone
who is cognizant about you know
things other than just learning but
their emotional state the safety
standards the getting
to and from school if you care about the
whole child
i think you are conquering the whole
picture
and we have some friends at this company
called erin condren and they heard about
what you were doing
and just wanted to step in and say thank
you
and they're a lifestyle brand and
they're known for organizational
essentials
in the home and the office i happen to
be very passionate about organization
it's one thing i can control as i grow
up and become
better organized and they want to donate
fifteen thousand dollars
worth of supplies uh to the faculty
and the students um including pens
notebooks walls calendars which is a
personal favorite of mine coloring books
and face masks
to you and your school thank you so much
that is so awesome
kids love gifts we we love to give
thanks to kids and teachers love gifts
too so they'll be super excited
we appreciate that so much and it's
supplies everybody can use and
really all of us at you know this show
and erin condren
were all just amazed by your story and
i can tell you as a human and a parent
thank you for everything that you're
doing thank you
miss janet thank you
[Music]